moi je vais mourir debout j'ai vécu deux
bouts je me suis battu pour avoir la vie
que j'ai je me suis battu pour l'hiver
j'ai maintenant je me bats pour pour
libeller j'appelle çà comme çà
l'interruption volontaire de vieillesse
[Musique]
e
ans
j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai voulu faire
c'est pour ça que je vous dis que
maintenant bon ben maintenant quoi c'est
durable et au début on n'est jamais en
pleine forme
jamais on est plus ou moins bien mais on
a des trucs on ad ce qu'on appelle les
pots de polypathologies de la vieillesse
moi par exemple j'ai trois vertèbres qui
sont fracturées à cause de l'ostéoporose
j'ai pas envie d'en parler maintenant je
vous en parle mais en réalité quand on
dit ah mais
tout va bien pourquoi évidemment il ya
beaucoup pire il ya beaucoup beaucoup
pire mais moi ce beaucoup pire j'ai pas
envie de le suivre en ce moment j'ai la
trouille
parce que je suis dans un appartement
tout seul je me casse la gueule
j'ai un avc j'ai un truc je t'ai reid en
france qu'est ce qui m'arrive
tout ce qu'on me propose c'est la nation
la sédation profonde et terminale
jusqu'à la mort ça veut dire que je
serai là comme un légume pendant pendant
quatre semaines jusqu'à ce que j'ai le
droit de mourir ben non si si je dois
mourir des souffrances affreuse si je
suis dans un accident et que j'ai des
douleurs terribles et tout ça oui ça
j'ai peur de ça mais si je sais que je
vais partir en tournant un robinet d'une
paire avec ça va être comme une
anesthésie générale
j'ai peur de quoi je profite de chaque
instant d'ailleurs chaque instant est
d'autant plus est d'autant plus intense
chaque instant épais et plus avec
justement cette ombre derrière de la
mort si vous pensez pas à la mort lors
la vie elle est
les monotone
[Musique]
je crois que mes enfants il souffrirait
beaucoup plus de voir une maman malade
dans un plumard dont il faudrait qu'ils
s'occupent dont ils sauraient pas quoi
faire parce qu'elle est malade qui
serait malheureuse parce qu'elle est
malade je crois que ce que je laisserai
à mes enfants
au contraire c'est l'image d'une femme
libre déterminé qui n'a pas peur
[Musique]
si c'était comme ça ben moi je serais
beaucoup plus tranquille je dirais bon
pourquoi janvier 2020 ça peut être
janvier 2022 ou 2023 janser ça peut être
au moment où j'aurai plus de
de force où je serai malade si je sais
qu'en france ce sera ok ben voila moi
j'aurais pas de problème je suis
heureuse je suis bien mais j'ai la
trouille moi maintenant je me dis que
c'est affreux la façon dont on meurt en
france